if you want corn here's how you get corn
you dig a hole in the ground and you
plant corn don't argue about it just
freaking do it if you tuned in wanting a
sophisticated radio show that would
cause you to go straight to sleep
buy boring finance professor you got the
wrong place this is God's and grandmas
ways of handling money common sense
you're gonna hear things that make you
say oh I already knew that because you
already knew it people don't tune in
here to get necessarily at tons of new
information are things to tickle your
brain or to make your intellect go into
spasms I don't have the ability to
provide that I do have the ability to
show you how to win with money but it's
deep things easy to understand things
like live on less than you make hmm we
can just go home now if you want if you
do that when the rest of it pretty well
work out won't it you could be generous
more than you are now
you could get out of debt more than you
are now you could save and invest more
than you are now
but you got to control you and you are a
salmon swimming upstream in an Instagram
world showing you how pretty and
beautiful and smart and wealthy everyone
else is and it's all fake because no
one's that pretty or smart or beautiful
I've seen all of you with makeup and
some of your just proof that all barns
need paint there is just none I mean
we're all this way people we're all this
way so the deal is common sense works
and some of the most profound things
you'll ever learn in your life are easy
to understand and hard to do because
they have to do with controlling you me
too I know how to lose weight that's
chocolate chip cookies knowing it and
doing it's two different things I like
chocolate chip cookies a lot it's a
problem I have done are you too huh okay
so we start teaching people 30 years ago
how to get out of debt
and I'm a math nerd and so I immediately
said you need to pay off the largest
interest rate first because that's
mathematically correct after doing this
for 30 years with millions of millions
means people I figured out that math is
not the only solution to personal
finance which is 80% behavior and 20%
head knowledge the way you get out of
debt is not about math you get sick and
tired of being sick and tired you
haven't I've had it moment where you say
that's it I've had it and until you've
had that moment I can't really help you
this is not an intellectual exercise
this is I'm pissed off at normal
exercise I'm not gonna be normal anymore
and I've got a righteous anger that's
rising up inside of me and I'm gonna
change my freakin life that's when you
get out of debt and then you list your
debts smallest to largest we call that
the debt snowball because it's behavior
based not math based and by the way it's
more successful than all the other crap
that some of you have as a theory you're
broke and writing a blog about finance
in your mother's basement nobody gives a
rip what you've got to say you haven't
got any proof as my young millennial
team tells me we need social proof we
need proof with people out there really
doing it well we've got like truckloads
buildings full of social proof 30 years
of social proof of you people doing this
stuff and winning more than any other
brand in America if you say Dave Ramsey
what do people say get out of that list
your debts smallest to largest well what
about what about shut up just do it
you're not the exception I know all
snowflakes are unique but they all are
subject to the law of gravity that's how
we have snowfall I get it you're special
but you're subject to the law of gravity
if you want corn here's how you get corn
you dig a hole in the ground and you
plant corn don't argue about it just
freaking do it list your deaths smallest
to largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little want to attack
the little one with a vengeance sell so
much stuff the kids think they're next
put the dog on eBay in the
cat on Craigslist get out of there baby
we're done amputate the Tahoe your
freaking car owns you
and you're gonna make a decision to live
different cuz normal sucks you don't
want to be normal anymore list your
death smallest to largest attack the
little one when the little ones gone you
take the payment that you had there and
every other ounce of money you can
squeeze out of your newfound life that
involves spending nothing and working
more and you pour it on that next debt
and when the two debts are gone you take
those two payments that you don't have
any more and more enthusiasm than you
ever had before and you put it on the
third one and by the time you pay off
three you're like oh yeah this is gonna
work see what hope does hope is more
powerful than math once you start to
believe then you'll sacrifice deeper
you'll work harder you'll really start
to do stuff that you're broke friends
think is nuts by the way if you're broke
friends are making fun of your financial
plan you are right on track sweetheart
if Instagram is appalled that your
newfound life you're right on track if
you find out that some of your Facebook
friends aren't real friends then you're
right on track because they weren't and
not everybody that likes something on
social media really likes it
I know these are shocking truths just
some of you but this is how life works
list your debts smallest to largest pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one attack the little one with a
vengeance and tear its butt off man get
those credit cards out light some
candles and have a plastic demean
ceremony let the children help you cut
them up so the children won't ask to use
them because they know they're gone let
them experience the death of plastic in
your house get you a couple of debit
cards and start paying for stuff you're
not in Congress buying crap you don't
have the money for this isn't hard it's
how you're supposed to live your life it
works
it's common sense if you want to know
why we're getting out of debt because
it's the shortest path to wealth
building when you don't have any
payments now you have the ability to
become wealthy it's the short it why do
you want to be wealthy won't change your
family tree retire with dignity
be the first old man or old lady who did
it right in your family tree oh and by
the way you can be outrageously generous
when you have wealth I've noticed that
poor people don't feed many hungry kids
I know you think wealthy people are evil
because you've been watching too much
stupid television but they're the ones
that feed the hungry people better than
the government does more efficiently
than the government doesn't more likely
than the government does that's what
happens in the real world look at the
billions of dollars Americans give away
every year in charity it's because they
had billions of dollars you have to
start with that so you get out of debt
so that you build wealth so that you
change your family tree so that you can
be outrageously generous